thor might be the god of thunder but the
real gods when it came to this
production were the gods of cgi we've
got 20 thor scenes without cgi coming at
ya that include everything from a mocap
suited up hella to chris hemsworth
hanging upside down by chains wait what
yeah you heard right let's go if anyone
knows how to land it's thor
nice work buddy
and just in case you doubted his power
the epic hammer does the trick is it
just us or is hemsworth exuding pure
glory
good for you god of thunder
need to look extra cool get you some
fans and voila superhero style
could there be a more boss way to enter
a scene okay so it looks weird at first
but that's what cgi is for
cate blanchett creeps in front of the
blue screen until bam cool green portal
appears blanchett did have a real hammer
and toe on set but for the most part
what we see was thanks to the techies
the grand master knows how to make a
grand entrance
at least with the help of a mechanized
platform and some of the strongest crew
members we've ever seen seriously a
round of applause for the platform guys
gotta give it to the master too he moves
very smoothly for a 14 million year old
let's stop there
what's he the god of
that's right thor's competition doesn't
look nearly as intimidating without the
special effects cue awkward-looking
motion capture bodysuits just because
they looked silly doesn't mean they were
gonna go easy on thor though the grim
mountain filled background is far from
the elaborate blue screen filled studio
they actually shot in but hey
does the trick
can you say quick change making that
swap happen quickly and on cue with
hemsworth's command was all thanks to
some image layering by the vfx team sure
the actors had to film the scene twice
in different clothing but surely that
was a heck of a lot easier than actually
figuring out how to magically change the
snap of thor's fingers a dash of
landscape a sprinkle of special lighting
and voila
every good god knows no throne room is
complete without a throne even before
cgi who needs the whole room once you've
got the elaborate throne anyway blue
screens and ramps pretty much do the
same thing until the time when vfx can
take over and dazzle
probably the best part about this cgi
magic is the fact that no one had to
sweep that enormously long hallway
you're in my seat
let's get one thing straight kate
blanchett knows how to work an amazing
cgi transformation running your fingers
through your hair is pretty special when
you're an asgardian goddess of death
nail
need some weapons and a full costume
real quick we can do you one better
blue screens
blanchett really brings it in this
electrifying scene okay well really it's
all the cgi team but still she gives off
the right vibe from the land to the
flurries of wind and the electric
current that lights up our screens a
masterful exhibition of both the vfx
team skills and hellas
two brothers both of them gods and
neither afraid to smack down yeah
they've got a complicated relationship
but they make a solid team hemsworth and
hiddleston's chemistry just makes it
even better
oh and all those cg backgrounds and
special effects to really convince us of
their godliness
um valkyrie you're supposed to stay
inside the ship tessa thompson is
clearly jacked that tight grip both on
the outside of the ship and when she's
at the wheel work thor has got some
pretty solid company when valkyrie is
around
at first glance it seems like there
wouldn't be too much cgi done for this
shot hemsworth is in a real environment
and in the grass but the transformation
between what was filmed and what we got
in the movie is stark
the most shocking of all
the grass unfortunately natural grass
wasn't quite up to snuff only the bit in
front of hemsworth stayed and even still
it was enhanced
watch out valkyrie coming in hot the
suit is great but what really does it
for us is the flowing blue cape
tessa thompson's ninja skills are on
point as she fights flies and performs
valkyrie with undeniable enthusiasm and
fire this scene was in reality a lot
less intimidating for the warriors who
instead of battle armor were kitted out
in those cute motion capture suits and
valiantly heading towards a very safe
looking blue screen instead of the chaos
we actually get in the movie these
incredibly detailed special effects help
these actors look as epic as possible
we've got regular thor fat thor and
digital thor
yes you heard that correctly the stellar
cgi team rendered a fully digital double
of hemsworth as thor that could be used
to fine tune the details when blended
with other special effects but it was
still all about hemsworth yep
the actor was being bodytracked the
whole time to use as a base plus they
wanted to capture all they could of that
pretty face so that when combined with
the digital thor we got the best thor
the power forces between these
characters is a bit insane but on the
set the whole situation looks much less
effective
blanchett rocks the scene sporting an
always funny-looking mocap suit managing
to perform as if she were kitted out to
the nines in hela's power suit not to
mention the headdress unfortunately this
piece only came to life in the computer
generated world although bland [ __ ]
probably didn't mind because honestly it
doesn't look like it would be the most
comfortable or practical piece to wear
to be honest i expected more need to
smoothly glide backwards chris hemsworth
might be offering a masterclass soon
hemsworth just got hooked up to wires
while the crew went at it with the giant
rig controlling the thor actors
movements
and it looks like it was quite the heavy
rig to control
when was the last time you were in a 160
000 person stadium never
same for the actors in this scene
because guess what
they're all made by computers
look how unthor like hemsworth looks
fighting a hulk that isn't even there
those punches just don't land
sorry chris parts of his arms and torso
weren't quite good enough so cgi leveled
up when hemsworth couldn't get help
no come on you love it i hate it
elevators were boring until now
this do-over hurst like mad to nail this
sequence and thanks to some cgi magic
they all pulled it off it was a bad day
to go against these brothers
oh classic thor hammer time and boy does
thor make it work he didn't always have
a real hammer but hemsworth knows the
power of the hammer and that was good
enough for the cameras until cgi could
jazz everything up
thor's got himself in a pickle hasn't he
gotta give it to hemsworth though he
managed to get all his dialogue out with
blood rushing to his head surger had it
pretty easy when the actual filming
happened waiting until the editing phase
to hop into that frame
so many people to reign over asgard so
little time
there was odin loki and then of course
everything that went down during
ragnarok
asgard was actually a pretty even combo
of real outdoor spaces and blue screen
filled studios but at the end of the day
we know
asgard is where our people stand
thank you mcu and cgi gods for bringing
all the magic we need to the screen
honestly we're really into hella in a
mocap suit which is your fave scene
without effects